has The Simpsons predicted the future
once again some fans think the events of
a 2006 episode are eerily similar to the
real life 2023 catastrophe of the Titan
submersible fans have often noticed that
the Simpsons has eerily predicted a lot
of things that have ended up coming true
for one Donald Trump's presidency
we've inherited quite a budget crunch
from president Trump the show is also
thought to have predicted several
different Super Bowl outcomes smart
watches Siegfried getting attacked by
his own tiger during a show the FIFA
corruption Scandal and Donald Trump
running for president again in 2024. the
list goes on and on now fans are saying
that the long-running Animated Series
also predicted the Titans immersible
imploding underwater while searching for
the wreckage of the Titanic in the
season 17 episode Homer's paternity coot
Homer thinks he's found his real father
a guy named Mason Fairbanks who's voiced
by guest star Michael York inexplicably
the two set out to find underwater
treasure in the wreckage of a ship
called the piso mojado which is Spanish
for wet floor Homer predictably gets
stuck in the wreckage he loses oxygen in
the deep ocean and wakes up in a
hospital a few days later meeting a very
different fate than the five people
aboard the Titan submersible yet fans
took to Twitter to claim that once again
The Simpsons seems to have predicted the
future on the one hand The Simpsons has
been on the air for so long since
December 1989 to be specific that it
feels like an inevitability that the
show would end up predicting some
real-life events by coincidence and that
seems to be the case with all the
instances fans have noticed that said
it's still freaking fans out how similar
this instance was to the real-life
tragedy one fan on Twitter wrote before
the determination was made that the sub
imploded and experts were thinking the
people inside were running out of
breathable air The Simpsons really
predicted the Titanic submarine
situation and that they would completely
run out of oxygen this is actually scary
another was clearly unsettled making the
simple Proclamation we live in a
simulation but it's worth pointing out
how different the real-life incident was
from the story of The Simpsons episode
the Titan submersible embarked on its
journey to explore the wreckage of the
Titanic on Sunday June 18 2023 with five
passengers aboard Ocean Gate founder
Stockton Rush Hamish Harding Paul Henry
nargale shazada dawood and dawood's 19
year old son Suleiman the problem
started pretty much immediately with the
Kraft's Communications failing within
the first two hours of the Voyage on
Thursday June 22nd officials determined
that the five passengers had perished
likely in an implosion in a press
conference after an extensive Search
rear Admiral John mauger who serves as
the commander of the First Coast Guard
District delivered the sobering news the
debris is consistent with a catastrophic
uh implosion of the vessel the experts
believe that the implosion happened
shortly after Communications were lost
especially after they found debris from
the Titan itself near the Titanic's
wreckage despite the differences another
Twitter user seemed to feel personally
targeted by the similarities to The
Simpsons episode writing before the
Thursday press conference every new
detail of this story feels like it was
engineered to drive me specifically
insane Mike Reese previous visitor to
Titanic wreckage and author of Simpsons
episodes moaning Lisa Stark raving dad
and the way we was says on chance for
survivors he's not optimistic that's
right Mike Reese former showrunner and
writer on The Simpsons has a personal
connection to the Expedition on June
19th he told BBC breakfast that he
wasn't hopeful about the fate of the
passengers on board and he knew better
than most I don't know how anyone's
going to be able to access it much less
bring it back up Reese has actually gone
on three separate Expeditions with Ocean
Gate the company that made the Titan and
he knows that their safety measures
weren't always great from personal
experience he even said that during all
of his Dives the crafts lost
communication with ground control I got
on the sub and at the back of my mind
was well I may never get off this thing
that's always with you you have to just
remember the early days of the space
program or the early days of Aviation
where you just make a lot of mistakes on
the way to figuring out what you're
doing there's still a lot of unanswered
questions where the Titan is concerned
and many of those answers might never
come in any case The Simpsons has the
weirdest possible connection to this
entire situation and its prediction
streak continues at least in the eyes of
fans
thank you